مسافة طويلة من المكان الذي كنت فيه
عندما بدأ كل هذا ، أريد أن أشغل
فيديو للناس من اليوم الرابع من
هذا من أجلك ، أعتقد أنك كنت في
المستشفى وبالكاد تستطيع التنفس ،
فلنشاهد مقاطع الفيديو في
الحمام ، ويشعر الحمام بخير  كأنني لا أستطيع أن أتنفس ، فكلما كان
التنفس أعمق هو أنني آخذ
الألم في الواقع يا رجل يجب أن أقول إن هذا أمر
مروع يمكنك أن ترى الصراع من أجل
التكاثر هناك ، لقد كتبت أنه كان مثل التواجد
تحت الماء ، هذا هو التشبيه
الذي استمر في إعطائه للناس الذين شعروا به
كأنني كنت تحت الماء لفترة طويلة جدًا
وصعدت ألهث بحثًا عن الهواء ، وفقط عندما
اعتقدت أنني كنت ألتقط أنفاسي مرة أخرى ،
تم سحبي تحت الماء وما
رأيته للتو كان يحدث ، تعلمون
ربما مرة كل ساعة كل
ساعتين وهذا  استمر في المجيء والذهاب
ولهذا السبب ظللت أقول لنفسي حسنًا إنني
أتحسن كما تعلم أحيانًا
قد أذهب لبضع ساعات دون أن
يحدث ذلك ثم على مدار
اليوم الخامس والسادس
بدأ يحدث أكثر وأكثر حتى ذلك
كان الأمر كذلك طوال الوقت
والليلة السابقة في المستشفى ، كنت في
الأساس هكذا لم أنم مطلقًا
لأنني لم أستطع
النوم وكنت خائفًا إذا كنت أنام كنت
قلقًا من أنني قد أتوقف عن التنفس
وهذا ما جعلته  من المحتمل أن أفكر في
حوالي الساعة الثالثة أو الرابعة صباحًا ،
أحتاج إلى أن أكون في المستشفى واتصلت
برقم 911 ، ربما كان ذلك في حوالي الساعة 7 صباحًا بحلول
الوقت الذي اتصلنا فيه بـ 9-1-1 ، هل يمكننا اللعب
مرة أخرى ، أريد فقط أن ألعب ذلك مرة أخرى  حتى
يتمكن الناس من رؤية مدى صعوبة الأمر بالنسبة لك
في الواقع من المستحيل الحصول على نفس كامل ،
لذلك دعونا نلعب مرة أخرى أشعر وكأنني
لا أستطيع التنفس كلما تعمقت في التنفس
كلما زاد الألم في الواقع ، فأنت تعرف
أحد أكثر الأشياء تقشعر لها الأبدان  لقد
كتبت جايسون هل كتبته إذا
طُرح عليك السؤال الذي تعرفه ، هل أنت
واثق من أنك ستعيش من خلال
هذا ، لا يمكنك إعطاء أمين إجابة صادقة
نعم II جلست في غرفة المستشفى
وأنت هناك بنفسك
خبرة الممرضات والأطباء
منخفضة للغاية  قصر وقتهم في
الغرفة ونهضت من السرير في وقت ما كنت
في اليوم الثاني عندما كنت قويًا بما يكفي
لأخرج من السرير
وحدقت من النافذة لفترة من الوقت وأجريت
محادثة صغيرة مع نفسي.
ستخرج من هنا وقلت
أعتقد ذلك ، لكنني أيضًا أشاهد التلفزيون
في المستشفى وأرى كل هذه
القصص عن الأشخاص الذين كانوا
يتمتعون بصحة جيدة وفي اليوم التالي كانوا في
المستشفى في اليوم التالي '
أنا ميت وأنا أقول من يدري أنني يمكن أن أتخذ منعطفًا سيئًا بعد
ساعة من الآن ، فأنت تعلم أنك لا
تعرف أبدًا وكان ذلك نوعًا من
لحظة التحقق من القناة الهضمية التي أصابتك حقًا
يمكننا سماعك بالطريقة التي تعرف بها
الثدي ليس مجانيًا بنسبة 100٪ ، أعني أنني
ما زلت أسمع التنفس كشيء
يجب عليك العمل عليه قليلاً
هناك في النهاية لم تكن بحاجة إلى
التنبيب ، لكنك حصلت على الأكسجين ما
جعلك أفضل من الأكسجين وأيضًا
أعطاني عقارًا يسمى levaquin
قالوا إنهم يأملون في الحصول
على الأمونيا  يقول كلا الجانبين ورئتيه السفليتين
أعطاني ليفاكين لمحاولة المساعدة في
مكافحة الالتهاب الرئوي والأكسجين ، لذلك
شعرت بالرعب أثناء مغادرتي من منزلي
لكن فريق الطوارئ الطبية سألني عما إذا كنت قادرًا على
عبور سيارة الإسعاف بمفردي لذلك
لم يفعلوا  يجب أن أذهب إلى
منزلنا المليء بالجراثيم في هذه المرحلة
وأخبرتهم نعم ، لقد نزلت نصف الطريق على
الدرج واضطررت لأخذ قسط من الراحة أخيرًا
نزلت إلى سيارة الإسعاف ووضعوا
الأكسجين في أنفي على الفور وكان الأمر كذلك
كانت سيارة الإسعاف روي في حالة استرخاء
لأنني تمكنت من التنفس لأول
مرة في الأيام
التي
أثبتت فيها إصابة جين كيم بفيروس كورونا
قبل ثلاثة أسابيع بعد عودته من
الولايات المتحدة ، وهو في المستشفى
منذ أن أعطاه اختبار سلبي هذا الأسبوع
الأمل في أنه تعافى ولكن  في اليوم التالي كانت نتيجة
اختباره إيجابية مرة أخرى ، يحتاج المريض
إلى سلبيتين متتاليتين ليتم
اعتباره قد تعافى ، لكن كيم يقول إنه حتى
بعد خروجه من المستشفى ، سوف
يعزل نفسه لمدة أسبوعين لحماية
عائلته مرة أخرى.
في الوقت الذي يجب أن تقوم عائلتي بالعزلة نفسها
مرة أخرى ، هناك قلق في جميع
أنحاء العالم من حالات الاختبار إيجابية
بعد أن يبدو أنها تعافت
من الفيروس نائب مدير مركز السيطرة على الأمراض في كوريا
يقول أن هناك أربعة
تفسيرات محتملة مجرد جسيم
والاختبار المحتمل
أيضًا إعادة التنشيط النهائي  يقول
الزنجي على مستوى يمكن اكتشافه من جسيم فيروسي ،
إن الاختبارات التي أجريت على عائلة مكونة من
ثلاثة أفراد ممن ثبتت إصابتهم بالفيروس
قد اكتملت بالفعل ولا يوجد دليل
على وجود الفيروس الحي في
أجسادهم ، ويعتقد أن بقايا الفيروس الميت
هي التفسير الأكثر ترجيحًا في  في هذه
النقطة ، يقول أيضًا إنه لا يوجد
مؤشر على أن المرضى المتعافين
معديون عندما يعيدون اختبارهم إيجابيًا
حتى الآن لا يوجد خطر يأمل وزير الخارجية
كوان في معرفة المزيد في غضون
أسبوعين تقريبًا بمجرد الانتهاء من الاختبارات على
أكثر من 100 حالة أخرى حيث
تعافى الأشخاص ثم ثبتت إصابتهم.  نصفهم ،
كما يقول ، لم تظهر عليهم أعراض على كيم ،
إنها مجرد حالة انتظار لما
تشعر به تجاه الأمهات  في الواقع ، بعد أن
اجتزت الاختبارات ، أطلق عليها اسم 19 شعرت
بالإحباط ، لكنني الآن أفضل حقًا
باولا هانكوكس سي إن إن سيول ،
لقد
كان هذا مؤلمًا تقول إيمي دريسكيل إن
فيروس كورونا جعلها في قبضة نائب
لن تتركها
لأسابيع كل نفس وكل حركة
كل  أنت تعلم أن رفع ذراعيك
يتدحرج في السرير ، كل شيء
مؤلم بعد أقل من ساعتين من
وصولها إلى المنزل من المستشفى ،
رن هاتفها ، كانت إدارة الصحة بالمقاطعة
تطرح الكثير من الأسئلة التي
رأيتها في الأسبوعين الماضيين
أين كنت  في الأسبوعين الأخيرين
ممن كنت على اتصال بمكان
عملي ، كانت وزارة الصحة تفعل
ما يُسمى تتبع جهات الاتصال ،
وعليك تتبع كل شخص يظهر بشكل
إيجابي ،
وتتبع خطواتها التي ذهبت إليها للعمل
، وكان على رئيسها والموظفين أن يكونوا  اتصلت بها ،
وذهبت إلى مطعم لتناول طعام الغداء ، وذهبت
إلى صالون تصفيف الشعر الخاص بها وكان لا بد من
الاتصال بها ، وذهبت إلى لعبة كليفلاند
كافالييرز ،
وقد تم الاتصال بجميع أفراد عائلتها الذين جلسوا معها بهذا
النوع من المتابعة  يحدث تتبع الإجراءات في
جميع أنحاء البلاد والعالم من
أولئك الذين يعانون من تفشي covin
19 القاتل في نيويورك إلى أولئك
المرتبطين بأول دولة كبرى في الولايات المتحدة.
تفشي المرض في ولاية واشنطن إلى
كاليفورنيا ، وهو المكان الأول الذي تم فيه الإعلان عن
طلب البقاء في المنزل على مستوى الولاية ،
ويقول الخبراء إنه بدون تتبع جهات الاتصال
واختبار كافٍ لأمريكا
والعالم لا يمكن إعادة فتحهما بأمان ،
سنكون عرضة لخطر عودة ظهور
هذا المرض ليس فقط  في الخريف ولكننا
نذهب إلى العام المقبل ، لذا فأنت تقول
بدون الاتصال بتتبع كمية هائلة
دون اختبار كمية هائلة ، يمكننا
أن نجد أنفسنا في المكان الذي
بدأنا فيه
، وأعتقد أننا قد نجد
أنفسنا معرضين لخطر عودة الظهور مرة أخرى
ولكننا  ليس لديه عدد كافٍ من الأشخاص
للقيام بالتتبع ، ويقدر مسؤولو الصحة في الولاية
أن هناك حوالي ألفي
شخص يقومون بهذا العمل الآن ، لكن جامعة جونز
هوبكنز تحذر من أننا بحاجة إلى
ما لا يقل عن 100000 في الوقت الحالي ، فإن تتبع جهات الاتصال
جيد فقط مثل ذاكرتك ، وهذا صعب
أعني من قبل  طلبات البقاء في المنزل ،
هل يمكنك تذكر جميع الأشخاص الذين كنت
على اتصال وثيق بهم على مدار أسبوعين
يقولون في المقهى
إنهم في متجر البقالة أو في
مطعم أو في مدرسة طفلك ،
وهذا هو المكان الذي توجد فيه التكنولوجيا الكبيرة مثل Google و
تتقدم شركة Apple قريبًا ، حيث سيكون لديهم قريبًا
تطبيقًا يمكنك تنزيله طواعية تم
إنشاؤه بواسطة إدارة الصحة حتى يتمكنوا من
رؤية بيانات الموقع التفصيلية من
هاتفك الخلوي ، ولكن قد يكون الجمهور
متقلبًا حيال ذلك نظرًا لمخاوف الخصوصية التي
لا يزال تتبع جهات الاتصال يتطلب إجراءات
جادة عمدة لوس أنجلوس  للضغط من
أجل المساعدة الفيدرالية ، سنحتاج على الأرجح إلى
مئات الآلاف من الأمريكيين
ليتم تشغيلهم ، ويجب أن يتم تمويلها من
قبل الفيدراليين
ولكن يتم تفعيلها محليًا  دريسكول
تم العثور على جهات الاتصال الخاصة بها ،
وأخبرتها وزارة الصحة أنه لم تظهر أي أعراض على أي منها
حتى الآن ولكن الاختبار لا يزال يمثل
مشكلة لم أخضع لأي اختبار إضافي